Pienso que ya es hora de empezar a hacer problemas que tengan que ver con desigualdades,
pero en esta ocasión,
me voy a tomar desigualdades cuadráticas.
Ya sabemos cómo manejar
las desigualdades cuadráticas,
y en esta ocasión tengo un problema,
que por cierto saqué, de la página de Khan Academy,
el cual vamos a poder resolver
con una desigualdad cuadrática.
Así que, pues vamos a ponernos las pilas,
vamos a ver qué dice...
dice,
Riley tiene una granja rectangular
de 200 metros de ancho. Es esta granja que tiene aquí.
Esta área está dividida en dos partes,
una parte cuadrada,
cuyo lado mide lo mismo que la longitud de la granja,
es esta parte de aquí,
es un cuadrado
cuyo lado mide la longitud de la granja,
que por cierto le vamos a llamar "l".
Donde cultiva aguacates,
aquí está lleno de aguacates.
Y el resto del área, que es donde ella vive,
justo por acá, es donde vive Riley.
Cada semana, Riley gasta tres pesos por metro cuadrado en el área en la que vive, ok.
En esta área que tiene aquí,
gasta 3 pesos por metro cuadrado
no sé bien porqué, supongo que
por suelo o por agua o por luz, no lo sé,
pero lo que ella calculó, es que su gasto total es
3 pesos por cada metro cuadrado.
en el área en la que vive,
que es justo ésta de aquí.
Y por otra parte,
ella gana 7 pesos por metro cuadrado
del área en la que cultiva aguacates.
Es decir, en esta área de aquí,
en esta área de verde,
ella gana 7 pesos por metro cuadrado,
por la venta de sus aguacates, de lujo.
De esta forma,
logra ahorrar algo de dinero cada semana.
Y justo esta frase es muy importante,
ahorita la vamos a analizar.
Escribe una desigualdad que modele esta situación.
Usa "l" para representar la longitud de la granja de Riley. Justo lo que te decía.
Esta longitud la vamos a llamar "l".
Resuelve la desigualdad y completa la proposición.
Y dice, respuesta,
Una desigualdad que modela el problema es,
y aquí vamos a poner
la desigualdad que necesitamos,
y por otra parte dice,
la longitud de la granja de Riley es,
y aquí tenemos opciones,
tenemos la opción mayor que,
mayor o igual a,
menor que,
menor o igual a,
y aquí vamos a poner a cuántos metros.
Así que para esto vamos a sacar nuestro pizarrón,
déjame traerlo por aquí,
ok y de hecho, en el pizarrón ya puse el problema,
así que ya lo podemos trabajar.
Vamos a leerlo otra vez con mucho cuidado
y vamos a ver qué podemos sacar de este problema,
dice,
Riley tiene una granja rectangular
de 200 metros de ancho.
Ok, la granja tiene 200 metros de ancho,
pero bueno esto se nota aquí,
200 metros, en este dibujo, ok.
Esta área está dividida en dos partes,
una parte cuadrada,
cuyo lado mide lo mismo que la longitud de la granja,
que es esta parte de aquí,
donde cultiva aguacates
y el resto del área que es donde ella vive, ok.
Ahora, lo primero
que quiero que pensemos es en áreas,
porque justo aquí habla de metros cuadrados,
de metro cuadrado, gasta 3 pesos por metro cuadrado y aquí gana 7 pesos por metro cuadrado.
Así que vamos a hablar de áreas.
Si yo me quiero fijar en el área de esta región de verde,
¿cómo la podríamos sacar?
Bueno, pues es muy fácil,
¿cuánto mide de lado este cuadrado?
Este cuadrado mide de lado "l",
de hecho, "l", es justo lo que no sabemos,
por lo tanto ,si queremos saber el área
de esta parte de verde,
de la parte que destina a la producción de aguacates,
entonces, vamos a multiplicar el lado que vale "l",
por el lado,
es lo que nosotros sabemos del área de un cuadrado,
no hay que espantarnos.
lado por lado, es "l" por "l",
que es "l" cuadrada.
Como el lado mide a "l", entonces "l" por "l"
me va a quedar "l" cuadrada, ok,
Ahora, vamos a hablar o vamos a pensar
qué es lo que pasa con la zona residencial.
Si nosotros queremos calcular el área
de esta parte de aquí,
¿cómo la podríamos obtener?
Bueno, vamos a ver cuánto mide de ancho
y cuánto mide de largo,
porque este es un rectángulo.
Lo que sí sé, es que de largo, mide "l",
es exactamente el mismo largo que mide este terreno,
su terreno completo, es "l".
Ahora, ¿cuánto mide de ancho?
¿cuánto vale esta parte de aquí?
y esta parte de aquí,
la podemos encontrar de muchas formas
le podríamos poner otra letra,
"m" o lo que sea,
pero creo que sería mucho más fácil
ponerlo o escribirlo,
todo como una función de "l".
Así que si nosotros sabemos
que este largo total vale 200 metros, ok,
y además que este lado vale "l",
entonces este lado de aquí debe de valer
pues 200 menos "l"... 200 menos "l"...
eso es muy importante y esa,
es una de las claves importantísimas de este problema.
y eso lo encontramos porque yo sé que este lado
mide "l", este lado mide "l",
todos los lados de aquí miden "l",
y este lado total mide 200 metros.
Así que si a 200 metros, es decir,
la distancia que hay de aquí, hasta acá,
le quitamos "l",
pues me queda este pedacito, este pedacito
de color salmón, que es justo lo que yo quiero,
y de aquí acá entonces, mide 200,
que son todo lo que medía este largo
menos este pedacito que vale "l", ok.
Y ahora sí, ya podemos sacar el área,
de esta parte, donde vive Riley.
Y para sacarla, pues hay que multiplicar,
base por altura o ancho por largo,
es decir, vamos a multiplicar "l",
"l" que es el largo,
por el ancho,
que vale 200 menos "l", ok,
y bueno, aquí podremos distribuir "l" por 200,
y "l" por "-l",
pero ahorita lo vamos a hacer en un segundo paso.
Lo único que quería saber,
es cuánto vale el área, el área de la parte de aguacate,
y cuánto vale el área,
el área de la zona residencial,
porque aquí lo vamos a utilizar.
Dice,
cada semana, Riley le gasta 3 pesos,
3 pesos por metro cuadrado,
en el área en la que vive, ok,
es decir, de esta área, ella gasta 3 pesos
por cada metro cuadrado
y bueno, si nosotros tenemos que esta área
está dada en metros cuadrados,
entonces lo que gasta ella,
vamos a ponerlo aquí...
lo que gasta...
es 3 pesos por metro cuadrado
del área en la que vive,
es decir, 3 pesos por el área en la que vive,
pero el área que vive es "l" por 200 menos "l",
3 pesos que multiplica a "l" que a su vez multiplica
"l" menos 200
no te confundas, no está tan difícil,
si a nosotros nos dicen que gasta
3 pesos por metro cuadrado, son estos 3,
en el área en la que vive,
pero el área en la que vive es ésta,
y esta área está dada en metros cuadrados,
que es justo lo que dice aquí, ok.
Ahora, por otra parte, me dice que ella gana...
y déjame cambiar de color...
ella gana 7 pesos por metro cuadrado,
del área en la que cultiva aguacates.
Entonces vamos a poner aquí lo que gana,
gana 7 pesos,
7 pesos por cada uno de los metros cuadrados,
en los que ella cultiva aguacates,
es decir, por la siembra de sus aguacates,
ella gana 7 pesos por metro cuadrado,
pero cuál es el área de esta parte de verde,
bueno es "l" cuadrada
por lo tanto,
si gana 7 pesos por cada metro cuadrado,
vamos a multiplicar 7 por "l" cuadrada,
de lujo, ok.
De la misma manera, podemos concluir que esto,
es lo que ella va a ganar y aquí tenemos lo que gana,
a comparación de lo que gasta,
porque el siguiente...
la siguiente oración, me dice algo muy importante,
yo hace rato estaba intentando resolver este problema,
y no me salía, y no me salía,
y ahora me doy cuenta
de cuál es la clave de este problema
está en esta oración,
que yo no había leído bien,
de esta forma,
logra ahorrar... ahorrar, algo de dinero cada semana
y es que esto es importantísimo,
Riley logra ahorrar, si logra ahorrar,
eso quiere decir que lo que gana,
es más grande de lo que gasta,
y es que esta es la clave de este problema.
Este problema tenía la desigualdad muy escondida,
si nosotros queremos ahorrar,
entonces ganamos más de lo que gastamos,
si aquí nos dicen,
la clave de que logra ahorrar algo de dinero,
eso quiere decir que gana más de lo que gasta...
Esta parte es más grande que esta parte
y aquí está mi desigualdad,
ella ganan más de lo que gasta
y aquí está la famosa desigualdad,
que nos preguntaba el problema,
7 pesos por "l" cuadrada,
es más grande que 3 pesos por "l"... por "l" menos 200
y con esta desigualdad voy a resolver el problema,
es más vamos a apuntarle aquí,
déjame poner un color neutro,
me gusta éste como color neutro...
7 pesos por "l" cuadrada,
como lo estamos dando en pesos, lo voy a poner así,
7 "l" cuadrada,
esto es más grande que tres veces,
"l" por "l" menos 200
y aquí está la famosa desigualdad
que modela esta situación.
Ya tenemos que esta respuesta
y ya la podemos poner en nuestra página
de Khan Academy en las respuestas.
Ahora quiero que te des cuenta de lo siguiente,
nos dice,
usa "l" para representar la longitud de la granja de Riley.
Ok, eso ya lo hicimos
y después nos pide que resolvamos la desigualdad
y completemos la proposición, ok.
Ahora, ya que tenemos esta desigualdad de aquí,
que te parece si ahora la resolvemos,
para encontrar que "l"
debe de ser mayor que,
mayor o igual,
menor que,
o menor o igual que una cierta cosa.
Y lo padre de esto,
es que tenemos una desigualdad cuadrática.
Ahora, te tengo una buena noticia, lo bueno
es que ya sabemos resolver ecuaciones cuadráticas,
desigualdades cuadráticas perdón.
Y entonces ya podemos resolver esta parte de aquí,
o espera,
es 200 menos "l", ya me equivoqué,
vamos a borrar, ¡changos!
Vamos a quitar esta parte de aquí,
porque es 200 menos "l"
con razón, algo me decía
que esto se veía medio raro,
ok, vamos a ponerlo aquí,
200 menos "l"...
y de igual manera aquí, 200 menos "l"...
con este cambio del signo todo saldría mal,
bueno, vamos a resolverlo,
vamos a utilizar este color...
y que me quedaría de multiplicar,
éste por éste y éste por éste,
bueno, tenemos "7l" cuadrada,
esto es más grande que "3l" por 200,
esto es lo mismo que "600l", ok,
y después "3l" por "-l",
me queda "-3l" cuadrada, ok.
Aquí tengo una desigualdad de segundo grado,
para resolver una desigualdad de segundo grado
yo lo que te recomiendo es que pasemos todos los términos de un lado de la desigualdad
y después intentemos
utilizar justo lo que ya sabemos,
así que este término de aquí, éste,
lo voy a pasar para acá, ok,
y este término de aquí, también lo voy a pasar para acá, para que todo quede del mismo lado,
y me va a quedar, "7l" cuadrada, ok ,
éste lo voy a pasar acá con signo contrario,
por lo tanto vamos a sumar,
tres veces "l" cuadrada,
lo que estoy haciendo, sumando tres veces "l" cuadrada, a ambos lados de la desigualdad
y nosotros sabemos
que cuando sumamos o restamos,
algo en una desigualdad, la desigualdad,
el signo de desigualdad, se conserva, ok,
esto tiene que ser más grande...
déjame cambiar al mismo color...
ah, no, no, no...
espera,
vamos a pasar esto también del otro lado,
así que vamos a pasarlo con este color...
este de aquí, lo voy a pasar como "-600l", ok,
por la misma razón
y esto es más grande que,
si éste se va con éste y éste se va con éste,
de este lado derecho
de la desigualdad me queda 0,
que es justo lo que yo quería,
pasar todo de este lado la desigualdad,
ahora, date cuenta que estos dos se pueden reducir,
por lo tanto vamos a trabajar con ellos,
"7l" cuadrada más "3l" cuadrada
es "10l" cuadrada, ok,
y aquí tengo "-600l"...
"-600l"
esto tiene que ser más grande que 0...
más grande que 0...
Ahora, yo tengo
esta expresión que tengo aquí
y ya podría empezar
a pensar sobre esta desigualdad que tengo aquí,
pero vamos a reducirla un poco,
lo que voy a hacer es dividir todo entre 10
de esta desigualdad,
y lo padre es que 10 es un número positivo
y como es un número positivo,
el signo la desigualdad no se voltea.
Recuerda que cuando se voltea,
es cuando multiplicamos
o dividimos, por una cantidad negativa,
pero el 10 es positivo,
por lo tanto se queda igual.
si divido todo entre 10,
me va a quedar "10l" cuadrada,
entre 10 me da "l" cuadrada, ok,
después tengo "-600l" entre 10 ,
es lo mismo que "60l",
se va un 0 con el 0,
solamente me queda "60l", ok,
este parece un 0 raro,
y esto a su vez es más grande...
y el signo se conserva porque el 10
es un número positivo...
que 0 entre 10 y 0 entre 10 pues sigue siendo 0,
por lo tanto nos quedamos con esto.
Ahora, justo en este momento es cuando tenemos que reflexionar como le hemos hecho en los vídeos pasados,
tengo algo de la forma
"l" cuadrada menos "60l" más grande que 0,
de aquí, podemos factorizar un poco y decir...
ah, déjame mover un poco esto para abajo...
ok...
vamos a moverlo para abajo, ok...
estuvo más o menos así...
Bien, vamos a continuar aquí.
Esta expresión de aquí puede factorizar una "l",
y me quedaría "l"...
"l" que multiplica...
bueno, en primer lugar va a multiplicara "l",
ok, "l" por "l" es "l" cuadrada
y en segundo lugar va a multiplicar a -60,
y ahora ya lo tengo aquí factorizado
y esto es más grande que 0,
y es cuando yo me pregunto,
¿dos números multiplicados son más grande que 0
cuando ocurre lo siguiente?
O que el primero es positivo y el segundo es positivo o que el primero es negativo y el segundo es negativo.
Recuerda, la multiplicación de dos números es más grande que 0, cuando ambos tienen el mismo signo,
por lo tanto, vamos a ponerlo aquí,
esto...
esto quiere decir,
que... ah...
y déjenme cambiar de color...
que ya sea...
ya sea... y voy a abrir un paréntesis...
que "l" sea más grande que 0,
que el primero sea más grande que 0,
y que el segundo... el segundo es"l" menos 60...
"l" menos 60,
también sea más grande que 0, ok,
esto puede ser uno de los casos,
o en su dado caso que pase lo contrario
¿y qué es que pase lo contrario?
Bueno, que "l" sea menor que 0...
que "l" sea menor que 0...
Déjame ponerlo así.
Sea menor que 0, que sea negativo,
y el otro... y el otro...
también sea negativo, es decir que "l" menos 60,
también sea un número menor que 0, de lujo,
estos son los únicos dos casos que pueden pasar,
para que se cumpla esta desigualdad,
así que vamos a trabajarlos.
En el primero tengo que "l" es mayor que 0,
y a su vez tiene que cumplir que "l"...
que "l"... sea más grande que 60,
lo único que hice fue sumar,
60 de ambos lados de esta desigualdad.
Y bueno,
algo que sea más grande que 0,
y a su vez que sea más grande que 60,
es algo que sea más grande que 60
por lo tanto de aquí, de estos dos,
lo podemos reducir
en algo que sea más grande que 60.
"l" debe de ser más grande que 60.
Esto es muy importante,
lo vamos a utilizar aquí o en su dado caso...
ah déjame cambiar de color...
o en su dado caso...
tengo estas dos de aquí,
vamos a ver qué me dicen,
o "l" es más pequeña que 0, ok,
o en su dado caso, déjame ponerlo por acá,
"l" es más pequeña que 60...
"l" es más pequeño que 60,
sumando 60 de ambos lados de esta desigualdad.
Ahora, algo que sea más pequeño que 0
y a su vez, sea más pequeño que 60,
de estas dos podemos sacar solamente una desigualdad
y la desigualdad que junta a ambas,
es que "l" es más pequeño que 0,
algo más pequeño que 60 y más pequeño que 0,
debe de ser algo más pequeño que 0, forzosamente,
si queremos
que se cumplan ambas desigualdades, ok.
O "l" es más grande que 60,
o "l" es más pequeño que 0,
y estas dos eles cumplen,
esta desigualdad que tengo aquí.
Ahora, creo que ya casi acabamos el problema,
solamente tenemos que hacer un poco de reflexión.
Ya tengo dos posibles soluciones y las voy a poner aquí.
O "l" es más grande que 60,
o en su dado caso "l" es más pequeño que 0.
pero "l" no puede ser más pequeño que 0
y eso es muy importante,
esta solución no puede ser cierta,
porque si "l" fuera algo más pequeña que 0,
tendría que ser un número negativo
y no podemos tener una longitud negativa,
yo nunca voy a un terreno que tenga -3 metros de largo, o -8  metros de largo, esto no tiene sentido,
necesitamos una cantidad positiva, por lo tanto,
es cuando puedo eliminar a éste.
Y esta es la tercera cosa
más importante de este problema,
cuando yo eliminó a esta solución,
entonces ya me quedo con una única posible solución,
que es la que voy a poner en la página ,
que es que "l" sea más grande que 60
y me voy a quedar solamente con esta,
así que es hora de poner todo lo que vimos...
todo lo que vimos...
y déjame pasar aquí a la página, dice,
tenemos que poner esta desigualdad
y que "l" es más grande que 60,
esta desigualdad, a ver si me acuerdo,
ok... pasemos a la página y dice,
vamos a poner la desigualdad que modela el problema,
y decía,
7 veces "l" elevado... elevado... ok ¡perfecto!
es éste, elevado al cuadrado,
esto...
esto tiene que ser más grande...
déjame ver, creo que es éste... ok ¡perfecto!
tiene que ser más grande que,
3 por "l" que multiplica a 200 menos "l",
¿te acuerdas?
¡Perfecto!
a 200 menos "l", ok.
Ya tenemos esta parte de aquí y después dice,
la longitud de la granja de Riley es,
y nos quedaba que era mayor que...
mayor que... mayor que... ok,
mayor que,
¿te acuerdas de los metros?
¡60!
¡60 metros!
Ok, vamos a comprobar la respuesta.
Y perfecto, tenemos la respuesta bien.
Bueno, pues creo que eso es todo por este vídeo,
nos vemos en el siguiente, hasta la próxima.